so there's a lot of young folks
undergrads grads uh they're also young
uh listen to this so is there you've
talked about a lot of fascinating stuff
that's like
there's ways that things are done
and there's actual solutions and they're
not always like intersecting
do you have advice for uh undergraduate
students or graduate students
or even people in high school now about
uh a life about career of
how they might be able to solve real big
problems in the world
how they should live their life in order
to have a chance to solve big problems
in the world
it's hard i i struggle a little bit
sometimes to give advice because the
advice that i give from my own personal
experience is necessarily distinct from
the advice that would make other people
successful i have
um unending ambitions to make things
better
i suppose and i don't see i don't see
barricades where other people
sometimes see barricades um now even
just little things like
when this virus started i'm a medical
director
at brigham a women's hospital and so i
oversee or help to oversee molecular
virology diagnostics
so when this virus started wearing my
epidemiology hat and wearing my sort of
viral
outbreak hat i recognized that this was
going to be a big virus that was
important at a global level
even if the cdc and who weren't ready to
admit that it was a pandemic it was
obvious in
january that it was a pandemic so i
started trying to get a test built
at the brigham which is one of harvard's
teaching hospitals
i you know the the first uh
encounters i had with the upper
administration of the hospital were
pretty much
no why would we do that that's silly who
are you
you know and i said well okay don't
believe me sure
but i kept pushing on it uh and then
eventually i got
them to agree it was really um only a
couple of weeks before the biogen
conference happened we started building
the test i think they started looking
abroad and saying okay this is happening
sure
like maybe he was right but
then i went a step further and i said um
we're not going to have enough tests
at the hospital and so uh so my ambition
was to get a better testing program
started
and and so i figured what better place
to scale up testing than the broad
institute
bird institutes is amazing you know very
high throughput high efficiency
research institute that does a lot of
genomic sequencing things like that
so i went to the broad and i said hey
you know there's this coronavirus
that's obviously going to impact our
society greatly
can we start modifying your high
efficiency
instruments and robots for coronavirus
testing
everyone in my in my
orbit in the hospital world just said
that's ridiculous you know how could you
possibly
plan to do that it's impossible you know
and
and to me it was like the most dead
simple thing to do
right it didn't it but the the higher
ups and the people who think about you
know the
i think one of the most important things
is to recognize that most people in the
world
don't see solutions they just see
problems and it's because it's an easy
thing to do
thinking of problems and how things will
go wrong
is really easy because you're not coming
up with a brand new solution
and this to me was just a super simple
solution hey let's get the broad to help
build tests every single hospital
director you know told me no
like it's impossible my own superiors
the ones i report to in the hospital
said you know mike you know you're a new
faculty member
your ideas you know probably will would
be right but you're too naive and young
to
to know that it's impossible right you
know obviously now the broad is
the highest uh throughput laboratory in
the country and yes you know
and so i think my recommendation to
people is as much as possible get out of
the
mode of thinking about things as
problems
sometimes you piss people off i could
probably use a better filter sometimes
to try to like be
not so upfront with certain things but
um but it's just so crucial to always
just see
to just bring like think think about
things in new ways that that other
people haven't
because usually there's something else
out there and and one of the things that
has been most beneficial to me which
is that my my education was really broad
it was engineering and physics
and well and then i became a buddhist
monk for a while and so that gave me a
different perspective
but then it was medicine and immunology
and
and now i've brought all of it together
from a mathematics and biology and
medicine perspective and policy and
public health and i think that you know
i'm not the best in any one of these
things
i i recognize that there are going to be
geniuses out there who are just worlds
better than me at any one of these
things that i
try to work on but my superpower is
bringing them all together you know and
just thinking and that's i think how you
can really
change the world um you know i don't
know that i'll ever change the world
in the way that i hope um but that's how
you can have a chance
yeah that's how you can have a chance
exactly and um
and i think it's also what uh you know
this to me this rapid testing program
like
this is the most dead simple solution in
the world and this literally could
change the world
it could change the world it could
change and it is you know there's
countries that are doing it now the us
isn't but i've been advising many
countries on it and
and i would say that you know some of
the early papers that we put out
earlier on a lot of the things actually
are changing you don't always
unless you really look hard you don't
know where you're actually having an
effect
um sometimes it's more overt than than
other times
in april i published a paper that was
saying hey with the pcr values from
these
tests we need to really focus on the ct
values the actual quantitative values of
these lab-based pcr tests
at the time all the physicians and
laboratory directors told me that was
stupid you know why would you do that
they're not accurate enough and and of
course now it's
headline news that you know the florida
they just mandated
reporting out the ct values of these
tests because there's a real utility of
them
you can understand public health from it
you can understand better clinical
management
uh you know that was a simple solution
to a pretty
difficult problem uh and it is
changing the way that we approach all of
the lab testing in this country is
starting to
it's taken a few months but it's
starting to change because of that and
you know that was just me saying hey
this is something we should be focusing
on
got some other people involved and other
people and and now
people recognize hey there's actual
value in this number that comes out of
these lab-based pcr tests so sometimes
it does grow
fairly quickly um but
i think the real answer if my only my
only answer i don't know
what you know i recognize that everyone
some people are going to be really
focused on
and have one small but deep skill set
i go the opposite direction i try to
bring bring things together and
um but the biggest thing i think is just
don't see problem don't
don't see barriers like just see like
there's always a solution to a barrier
if there's a barrier that literally
means a solution to it that's why it's
called a barrier
and just like you said most people will
just present
to you only be thinking about it and
present to you with barriers
and so it's easy to start thinking
that's all there is in this world
yeah and just think big i mean god you
know there's nothing wrong with thinking
big
elon musk got big and you know and then
thinking big builds on itself you know
you you get a billion dollars
from one big idea and then that allows
you to make three new big ideas and
there's a hunger for it
if you think big and you communicate
that vision with the world
all the most brilliant and like
passionate people will just like
you'll attract them and they'll come to
you and then it makes your life actually
really exciting the people i've met
at like tesla and uh neurolink i mean
there's just like this fire in their
eyes they just love life and
uh it's amazing i think to to be around
those people
you